This is 99% Invisible. I'm Roman Mars. A Rishikesh her way has a podcast called Song Exploder. The concept is simple but brilliant. I ask musicians to take apart one of their songs and go through it piece by piece and let listeners hear what's going on inside some of the tracks and reveal the secrets of what went into making the song, whether it's some of the sounds inside of it or just the memories of what they were going through when they were creating the song. I don't think Hershey would mind me saying, but it's kind of a design show about music. 99% indisible for songs. On the very first episode of Song Exploder, Richie interviewed Jimmy Tamborello of the band The Postal Service and invited him to take a deep dive into each individual element of the song, the district sleeps alone tonight.
这里是《99%隐形》。我是罗曼·马斯。Hrishikesh Hirway有一个播客叫做《Song Exploder》。这个概念很简单但很精彩。我请音乐人拆解他们的一首歌，一小节一小节地剖析，让听众听到某些音轨内部的声音，并揭示制作这首歌背后的秘密，无论是其中的某些声音，还是他们创作这首歌时的记忆。我觉得Hrishikesh不会介意我这么说，但这有点像是一个关于音乐的设计节目。《99%隐形》音乐版。在《Song Exploder》的第一期节目中，Hrishikesh采访了邮政服务乐队（The Postal Service）的吉米·坦博雷洛（Jimmy Tamborello），并邀请他深入探讨这首歌《今晚区政区独自入眠》（The District Sleeps Alone Tonight）的每一个独立元素。
It's the song that's playing behind me now. If you don't already own the lone postal service album, you've made some bored choices in life. I'm serious. Anyway, this is Jimmy Temberello isolating the backing vocal track, sung by Jenny Lewis. So here's some of Jenny's background vocals so I load out. I am a visitor here. I am not permanent. Where are you? So Timbrella was looking to add more texture to the final mix of the song and he had these beautiful backing vocals. It might have been just an accident with a delay pedal but I've looped a little bit of Jenny's vocals and made into texture in the song. I was one of the last things that we put into that into the district.
这就是现在在我身后播放的歌。如果你还没买过邮政服务乐队的那张唯一的专辑，你在生活中可做了一些无聊的选择。我是认真的。不管怎样，这是吉米·坦博雷洛隔离出来的和声伴唱音轨，由珍妮·刘易斯（Jenny Lewis）演唱。所以这是我独奏出的珍妮的一些背景和声。我是这里的访客。我不是永久的。你在哪？所以坦博雷洛希望为这首歌的最终混音增加更多质感，他有了这些优美的背景和声。这可能只是延迟踏板的一个意外，但我把珍妮的一小段人声循环播放，做成了这首歌里的质感。这是我们放到那首《区》里的最后几样东西之一。
You can play that part by itself. This vocal loop comes in after the second verse when it's going into the more dancing outro part. Here's where she gets her way from the song Exploder again. I'd heard that song the district sleeps alone tonight. I mean, so many times since it came out in 2003, and I knew that part and I knew that sound, I had no idea that that was a human voice making that sound until he took everything away.
你可以单独播放那部分。这段人声循环出现在第二段主歌之后、过渡到更具舞曲风格的尾奏部分时。下面再次请出《Song Exploder》的Hrishikesh。自从这首歌在2003年发行以来，我听过《今晚区政区独自入眠》这首歌无数次，我知道那个部分，也知道那个声音，但我完全不知道那是人类的声音发出的，直到他把所有其他东西都去掉。
And that was the first episode. That was sort of like the pilot before the show was called Song Exploder, when I was still sort of figuring it out. And when Jimmy played that part, I was like, oh, this is it. This is the reason why I want to do this show and a radio show was born or podcast whatever. As opposed to like a magic trick where the intention is to fool the audience into thinking that their experience is something that they aren't. If you're learning all the
那是第一集。那有点像试播集，在节目还叫《Song Exploder》之前，当时我还在摸索中。当吉米播放那段时，我想，哦，就是这个。这就是我想做这个节目的原因，一个广播节目就这样诞生了，或者说播客，随便什么吧。不同于魔术，魔术的目的是愚弄观众，让他们以为体验到的东西并非现实。如果你了解了所有的
secrets of a song, the idea is still to just create a musical experience for you that you enjoy. And I feel like you once you know more about it, then you can have a richer enjoyment of it. Or at least that's how it is for me. So say we all. Today we're going to feature a recent episode of Song Exploder, all about the theme song to the Netflix original series, House of Cards.
一首歌的秘密，其目的依然是为你创造一个你所享受的音乐体验。我觉得一旦你对它有了更多了解，你就能获得更丰富的享受。或者至少对我来说是这样的。我们大家都有同感。今天我们将推出《Song Exploder》最近的一期节目，全部关于Netflix原创剧集《纸牌屋》的主题曲。
This is one of my favorite episodes because it reveals so much about all the thought that goes into making a theme song to a TV show. Horseshoe spoke to the composer Jeff Beale and his home in Los Angeles and he described his collaboration with the series executive producers David Fincher and Bo Willemman, how they established the tone and musical palette of the show, and how the music theme changed from season 1 to season 2, which hadn't even noticed, but sure enough, go back, totally different. You're currently hearing the season 1 version.
这是我最喜欢的单集之一，因为它揭示了大量关于为电视剧制作主题曲所投入的心思。Hrishikesh在洛杉矶的家中采访了作曲家杰夫·比尔（Jeff Beale），他描述了他与该剧执行制片人大卫·芬奇（David Fincher）和鲍尔·威利蒙（Beau Willimon）的合作，他们是如何确立该剧的基调和音乐调色板的，以及音乐主题是如何从第一季演变到第二季的——我甚至都没注意到，但果不其然，回去听听，完全不同。你现在听到的是第一季的版本。
By the way, there's House of Guard season one spoilers ahead, so you've been warned. Here is composer Jeff Beale talking to her she gets her way on song explainer. I'm Jeff Beale, composer. I do the music for House of Cards. I had work with David Fincher on a commercial, probably about six or seven years ago. And this was around the time I had been working
顺便说一下，接下来会有《纸牌屋》第一季的剧透，所以你已经被警告过了。这里是作曲家杰夫·比尔在《Song Exploder》上与Hrishikesh交谈。我是杰夫·比尔，作曲家。我为《纸牌屋》创作音乐。我大约六七年前和大卫·芬奇在一个商业广告上合作过。这大概是我一直在做
on Rome series for HBO. So I saw on the trades, this show was happening with David's name attached and I kept in touch and we'd never worked together since. And I thought this might be a good match for us. I'd watched a little bit of the British show and I was, I think there was part of my pitch to David is that because I sort of used the Rome thing. I said, well, I said, you know. I'd watch a little bit of the British show, and I think that was part of my pitch to David, because I sort of used the Rome thing, and I said, well, I said, you know,
HBO的《罗马》系列剧的时期。所以我在行业报刊上看到这部挂着大卫名字的剧正在制作，我保持了联系，但我们自那以后再没有合作过。我想这可能对我们来说是个绝佳的契约。我看了一点英国原版剧集，我想，我向大卫推销的一部分原因是因为我借鉴了《罗马》的经验。我说，嗯，我说，你知道的。我看了一点英国原版剧集，我想，这也是我向大卫推销的一部分原因，因为我借鉴了《罗马》的经验，我说，嗯，我说，你知道的，
even though Rome was a period of Rome, it was very much about politics and sort of operatic scale, cast, and storytelling. After I first met with David to sort of talk about the project, and got his initial thoughts about music, and we sort of put our heads together, based on his sort of way of thinking about music, and how much music informs his choices. He actually asked me to write some sketches before he started shooting. And of course, before we had the meeting and before I wrote these sketches, they shared with me, I think, about four or five scripts early drafts of what became season one. So it was very much Bose, Bose sense of language in the way he sort of created this world that
尽管《罗马》是一个历史时期，但它很大程度上关乎政治以及歌剧般的宏大叙事、演员阵容和故事讲述。在我第一次与大卫会面讨论这个项目并听取了他对音乐的最初想法后，我们根据他思考音乐的方式以及音乐对他选择的影响程度，把各自的想法结合在了一起。他实际上要求我在他开始拍摄之前写一些草稿。当然，在我们开会之前、在我写这些草稿之前，他们与我分享了大约四五份剧本的早期草稿，也就是后来成为第一季的内容。因此，很大程度上是鲍尔的语言感以及他构建这个世界的方式
inspired some of the early, early work. The thing I liked about the British show is this sort of dark humor to it. And I said, yeah, the music's definitely going to have to find a way to sort of give the audience permission to sort of laugh, the sardonic darkness. Of course, once he called me in, you know, he gave me some of his thoughts on it, which we're interesting, and some of them surprising to me, it's there was one song he really liked, the super tramp crime of the century. ["The Climber of the Century"] ["The Climber of the Century"] ["The Climber of the Century"]
启发了部分最初的早期工作。我喜欢这部英国剧集的地方在于它那种黑色幽默。我说，是的，音乐绝对得找到一种方式，给观众一种许可去发笑，那种讽刺的黑暗感。当然，一旦他把我叫去，你知道的，他告诉我一些他的想法，这些想法很有趣，其中有些让我感到惊讶，有一首歌他真的很喜欢，那是超脱乐队（Superteam）的《世纪罪行》（Crime of the Century）。[《世纪罪行》] [《世纪罪行》] [《世纪罪行》]
["The Climber of the Century"] Just a great song, a section of that song towards the end where it just becomes a sort of driving piece. ["The Climber of the Century"] It had this sense of sort of operatic sort of classicism and sort of gravitas, but it also had a very gritty, earthy and almost jazzy or bluesy kind of instrumentation or rock and roll. You know, as we dissected that together and sort of thought about why that spoke to him, that's the show. The show is, it's all about the underbelly of Washington.
[《世纪罪行》] 这真是一首伟大的歌，那首歌接近尾声的一个部分，变成了一种强劲的驱动力乐段。[《世纪罪行》] 它有一种歌剧般的古典感和庄严感，但它同时也有非常粗粝、质朴、几乎带有爵士或布鲁斯风格的配器，或者说摇滚乐。你知道，当我们一起剖析这一点并思考为什么这能打动他时，这就是这部剧。这部剧，它讲述的全是华盛顿见不得光的阴暗面。
The dark corner is what you don't see and what really happens is opposed to sort of the West Wing, you know, heroic, more aspirational. The sort of hail to the chief, you know, Washington, your typical sort of film score, gestures about the capital and politics. I wrote about four sketches for David. One of the things that became the main title theme. It's got that bass line, it's got that sort of cloud, a dark electronics that sort of precede it like a fog or something.
阴暗的角落，那些你看不到的东西以及真实发生的事情，这与那种《白宫群英》式的、英雄主义的、更有抱负的风格截然不同。那种“向总统致敬”式的华盛顿，那种关于首都和政治的典型电影配乐手法。我为大卫写了大约四首草稿。其中一个最终成为了主标题主题曲。它有那种低音线条，有那种像雾气一样在它前面浮现的、阴暗的电子音乐。
And the tune is there, although in this case, it was just played by the piano, a very simple orchestration. And then in the second time, it goes around, the snare drum comes in. Very simple, but there's a tune in there. There's a little sequence of chords and melody. Part of the reason sketching is useful is because it's like the bones of something. If the structure of the skeleton has integrity, it should be able to stand without an abundance
曲调就在那里，虽然在这个例子中，它只是由钢琴演奏的，配器非常简单。然后第二遍循环时，小军鼓进来了。非常简单，但里面有一段曲调。有一小段和弦与旋律的序列。做草稿之所以有用，部分原因是因为它就像是某事物的骨骼。如果骨架结构具有完整性，它就应该能够在没有大量
of sort of instrumental embellishment. And so by sketching and by doing simple versions of themes, you were able to sort of make sure that you have an idea. I always thought of this as sort of the puppet master theme, the idea that like Kevin Spacey's character is just a sort of manipulator who's a virtuoso at pulling the strings on people and getting them to do what he wants them to do. But the reason I'm sharing this one in the context of the main title is when we got around to finally doing the arrangement, David said he'd be cool if the main title felt like this
某种乐器点缀的情况下独立支撑。因此，通过打草稿和制作主题的简化版本，你能够确保自己有一个核心构思。我一直认为这有点像“提线木偶”主题，这个想法就像凯文·斯派シー（Kevin Spacey）的角色只是一个操纵者，是操纵人们、让他们按他的意愿行事的行家里手。但我把这个放在主标题的背景下来分享的原因是，当我们最终着手进行编曲时，大卫说，如果主标题听起来像是
sort of stew of a lot of different elements from the score, which would then be deconstructed into its individual parts. So you'll hear this sort of descending chromatic line in the high piano that became one of the signature of the main title sequence. As the sketch grows, the electric bass comes in. So it's this sort of minimalist piano motif by putting that bass under it, it sort of gave it a tension of something that's pushing against it. David and I talked about the piano a little bit because that was in the Super
来自配乐的许多不同元素的某种炖汤，然后再将其解构为各个独立的组成部分，那会很酷。所以你会听到高音钢琴中那种下行的半音阶线条，它成为了主标题序列的标志之一。随着草稿的丰满，电贝斯加入了进来。所以这是一种极简主义的钢琴动机，通过在它下面加入贝斯，它产生了一种与之对抗的张力。我和大卫聊了一会儿钢琴，因为那首超脱乐队的歌曲里有钢琴，而且那是我非常喜欢的乐器，它感觉像是凯文角色的绝佳乐器，因为它可以非常精确，在某种程度上也非常机械，我非常喜欢这一点。
Tramp Q and it's an instrument I like a lot and it felt like a good instrument for Kevin's character because it can be very precise and very sort of mechanical in a way, which I love about it. The sort of called arm things that was dropped into the main title sequence and it never left. Once it was in there, that was what we're going to do. And I started, you know, a few passes through. I started to work on the arrangement. The story of the main title sequence is visually lyrical and flowing, but I remember this came straight from sort of those original scripting of the main title.
那种所谓的号角元素被放进了主标题序列中，就再也没有离开过。一旦它进去了，这就是我们要采用的方案。我开始，你知道的，经过几次修改后，我开始着手编曲。主标题序列的故事在视觉上是抒情且流畅的，但我记得这直接来自主标题的最初剧本构思。
It's basically the whole idea of the sun going down in Washington. You know, you started in really broad daylight and as the sequence progresses, you end up in night. So, you, so there was a way in which you went from something very open and airy and light to like the darkness falling, you know. So that was, that was a little bit of a visual storytelling thing I tried to play off of. The first thing we hear is the fog, the fog of the cloud of doom. It's this sort of low synth drone.
它基本上就是华盛顿日落的整个概念。你知道，你从真正明亮的日光开始，随着序列的推进，你最终迎来了夜晚。所以，你知道的，有一种方式让你从非常开阔、轻盈、明亮的东西过渡到黑暗降临，你知道的。所以，这、这是一个我试图呼应的视觉叙事小技巧。我们听到的第一件事是雾，厄运之云的雾。这是一种低沉的合成器持续低音。
Shortly after that comes the bass line. Which I know David affectionately refer to as the rip tide. I always like that description. It's kind of like the idea of something that pulls you under, you know. Basically it's a combination of several things. It's analog-y, modeled, sin-things that I've designed, some of my hat for a long time. There's a couple different of those base samples mixed together, but I also record a live base player playing the part. It's actually my son, Henry, who is a
紧随其后的是贝斯线条。我知道大卫亲切地称之为“激流”。我一直很喜欢这个描述。这有点像某种把你往下拽的东西的概念，你知道的。基本上它是几种东西的结合。它是我用了很长时间的、模拟建模的、我自己设计的合成器音色。有几种不同的那些贝斯样本混合在一起，但我也录制了一位现场贝斯手演奏这个部分。实际上是我儿子亨利，他是一个
wonderful young musician. He's actually now studying jazz bass. The bass line was so important, and the orchestration was getting big enough. I actually recorded the bass an octave above. It gives it enough mid-rate content so that when all this other stuff is happening, that bass is still driving. One of the fun things about the composition for me was that the harmony changes a lot over that bass line. In fact, bass is always playing an A minor, but the harmony sometimes goes to A major. And it creates this very strange dissonance in this sense of collision. It's basically a wrong note, you know. It's like the bass player is playing the wrong note, but it doesn't sound like a wrong note because it's a synchrony, it's got its own logic to it. It's almost like
出色的年轻音乐人。他现在正在学习爵士贝斯。贝斯线条非常重要，而且配器的规模也变得足够大。我实际上把贝斯提高了八度进行录制。这赋予了它足够的在中频段的厚度，以至于当所有其他这些东西都在发生时，那个贝斯依然充满驱动力。对我来说，创作的乐趣之一在于，和声在这段贝斯线条上方发生了很大的变化。事实上，贝斯弹奏的始终是A小调，但和声有时会走向A大调。这就产生了非常奇怪的不协和音和冲突感。这基本上就是一个错音，你知道的。这就好比贝斯手弹错了音，但听起来又不像错音，因为它是一种同步，它有它自己的逻辑。这几乎就像是
Frank will push through anything, he doesn't care, he's not going to stop playing those notes. My original sort of called arm sketch two times through, which is kind of the original demo, was almost long enough to cover the main title sequence, but we needed some more time. And I also had this direction from David to sort of work in another theme. So what I did was I kind of extended the intro. I added a lot of percussion, but I also added that little pupper master riff, the da da da da da da da da. You know, that thing, it has a slightly different cadence because this is in 4-4, and the pupper master theme was always in 3.
弗兰克会冲破一切阻碍，他不在乎，他不会停止弹奏那些音符。我最初的那首演奏了两遍的号角草稿，也就是最初的小样，几乎长到足以覆盖主标题序列，但我们需要更多时间。而且我还收到了来自大卫的指示，要在其中融入另一个主题。所以我做的是，我有点延长了前奏。我添加了大量打击乐，但我也加入了那个小小的木偶师重复段，哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒。你知道的，那个东西，它的节奏略有不同，因为这是四四拍的，而木偶师主题一直是三拍的。
Frazes are broken up a little bit, but it's still got that descending chromatic line. Another layer that was sort of one of the last things I came up with, but was really useful is the trumpet. I'm a trumpet player, and again, it's the most expected cliche thing you'd hear, you know, show about Washington would be that sort of military trumpet kind of thing. And it's the most expected cliche thing you'd hear in a show about Washington would be that
乐句被稍微打碎了，但它仍然保留着那个下行的半音阶线条。另一层算是我最后想出的东西之一，但真的很有用，那就是小号。我是一个小号手，再说一次，这是你在关于华盛顿的节目中听到的最意料之中、最老套的东西，你知道的，那种军号似的东西。这也是你在关于华盛顿的节目中听到的最意料之中、最老套的东西
sort of military trumpet kind of thing. Because we're seeing the sort of iconic shots of Washington, it just felt right to have something that references that icon. Because obviously the rest of the composition is telling you that this isn't the heroic version of the Lincoln Memorial and the Washington monument. And there's a way in which it's sort of lonely to me too. I like the sort of loneliness of it. One of the things David visually did was to pull out a lot of the people in some of the time-lapse shots he has. It was much creepier seeing some of those shots with no people in them. It just made
那种军号似的东西。因为我们看到的是华盛顿的那些标志性镜头，放一个能让人联想到这种标志的东西感觉非常对。因为很显然，其余的编曲在告诉你，这不是林肯纪念堂和华盛顿纪念碑的英雄主义版本。而且在某种程度上，它对我来说也有点孤独感。我喜欢那种孤独感。大卫在视觉上做的一件事，就是在他的某些延时摄影镜头中移除了许多人群。看到其中一些镜头里空无一人，会让人觉得毛骨悚然。它只是让
it feel like he was a ghost town or had this sort of surreal quality to it. It's basically in talking to David Fincher about the second season. I was just sort of surprising to me, but I think we were spotting the first couple episodes. He sort of tried to give you notes on the main title about what he wanted different. David saw the second season as even more operatic and darker, too, which was shocking to me because the first season was pretty dark. But you know who everybody is. You've seen who Frank is and what he can do.
它感觉像是一座鬼城，或者带有一种超现实的品质。基本上，在与大卫·芬奇讨论第二季时。这对我来说有点意外，但我想我们当时在为前几集对画面。他试图就主标题给你提出修改意见，告诉你他想要什么不同。大卫将第二季视为更加歌剧化也更加黑暗，这对我来说很震惊，因为第一季已经够黑暗了。但你知道每个人都是谁。你已经看清了弗兰克是谁以及他能做什么。
He's killed somebody in the first season. I mean, it's obviously very, nothing's going to get in the way of what this guy wants to do. In general, for main titles, people get attached, especially when they like something. So it's very careful, you know, to like steer the ship enough, but not so far as to make it feel like your old friend was not your old friend anymore. So I added some voices, some voice samples to a lot of it. I also added some low strings to the intro.
他在第一季中杀过人。我的意思是，这显然非常明确，没有什么能阻挡这个家伙想做的事情。总的来说，对于主标题，人们会产生依恋，特别是当他们喜欢某些东西的时候。所以你要非常小心，你知道的，既要掌好舵，又不能幅度太大，以免让人觉得你的老朋友不再是你的老朋友了。所以我加入了一些人声，一些人声样本到很多地方。我还在前奏中加入了一些低音弦乐。
The high string line that used to be, you know, sort of pup a master theme, we just do that in the celly. So again, it's lower, everything's sort of skewing down, skewing darker, and so that it feels like this cloud has sort of come over the whole thing. The sort of lightness and sense of that type of energy is dissipated. You know, he's no longer the puppet master. He's ever the vice president in season two. We know he's very much in command, so there's less of a game going on and much more of a,
曾经作为木偶师主题的高音弦乐线条，我们现在改用大提琴（cello）来演奏。所以再次说明，它更低了，一切都在向下倾斜、向黑暗倾斜，让人感觉这团乌云已经笼罩了整个事物。那种轻盈感和那种能量感已经消散了。你知道的，他不再是木偶师了。他在第二季里已经是副总统了。我们知道他完全掌控着一切，所以游戏成分减少了，更多的是一种
it's like the Ascent to the Throne. You know, I think so many networks, for even filmmakers are afraid of a real main title sequence. It's sort of an old-fashioned idea, but the whole idea of a little mini film that settles you into a world and gets you ready to experience something is a wonderful sort of a storytelling device. You know, it sort of frames a moment for you and gets you settled into what you're about
这就像是登上王座。你知道，我认为很多电视网甚至电影制作人都害怕真正的主题曲序列。这有点像个老派的想法，但制作一个小型的迷你电影，让你平静下来进入一个世界，并让你准备好体验某些东西的整个概念，是一种绝妙的叙事手段。你知道，它为你定格了一个时刻，并让你安顿下来，准备好去接受你即将
to take in. And now here's the season two version of'm going to go to the next room. I'm going to go to the next room. I'm going to go to the next room. I'm going to go to the next room. I'm going to go to the next room. I'm going to go to the next room. I'm going to go to the next room. I'm going to go to the next room.
去体验的内容。现在这是第二季的版本。我要去隔壁房间。我要去隔壁房间。我要去隔壁房间。我要去隔壁房间。我要去隔壁房间。我要去隔壁房间。我要去隔壁房间。我要去隔壁房间。
I'm going to go to the next room. I'm going to go to the next room. I'm going to go to the next room. I'm going to go to the next room. I'm going to go to the next room. 1.5% 1.5% 1.5% 1.5% 1.5% 1.5% 1.5%
我要去隔壁房间。我要去隔壁房间。我要去隔壁房间。我要去隔壁房间。我要去隔壁房间。1.5% 1.5% 1.5% 1.5% 1.5% 1.5% 1.5%
1.5% 1.5% 1.5% 1.5% 1.5% 1.5% 1.5% . 1 tbc 1 tbc 1 tbc 1 tbc 1 tbc
1 tbc 1 tbc 1 tbc 1 tbc 1 tbc 1 tbc 1 tbc 1 tbc 1 tbc 1 tbc . That was song-exploder, on 99% of visible.
1 tbc 1 tbc 1 tbc 1 tbc 1 tbc 1 tbc 1 tbc 1 tbc 1 tbc 1 tbc . 以上是《99%隐形》节目的《Song Exploder》。
It was produced by Hiroshikeshirwe, who is also the driving force behind the band, the one a.m. radio, who is playing behind me right now. Song Exploder is part of the Maximum Fund Network, which shows like the memory palace bullseye with Jesse Thorn, judge John Hodgman, my brother, my brother and me, all kinds of good stuff. I have been a listener and monthly donor for years. You will find a show you love at MaximumFond.org. 99% Invisible is Sam Greenspan, KB Mingle, Avery, Truffleman, and me Roman Mars. We are a project of 91.7 Local Public Radio KALW in San Francisco and produced out of
本节目由Hrishikesh Hirway制作，他也是乐队“The One A.M. Radio”的幕后推手，该乐队目前正在我身后演奏。《Song Exploder》是Maximum Fun网络的一部分，该网络还拥有诸如《The Memory Palace》、《Bullseye with Jesse Thorn》、《Judge John Hodgman》、《My Brother, My Brother and Me》等各种好节目。多年来我一直是他们的听众和月度捐赠者。你可以在MaximumFond.org找到你喜爱的节目。《99%隐形》的制作人员有萨姆·格林斯潘（Sam Greenspan）、KB·明格（KB Mingle）、艾弗里·特拉夫曼（Avery Truffleman）以及我罗曼·马斯。我们是旧金山91.7地方公共广播电台KALW的项目，并在位于
the offices of Arxon. Collaboration-minded architecture firm in collaboration-minded Oakland, California. You can keep up with this show and all the people who make this show on Facebook, Twitter, and Tumblr. We are very interesting in all of those places. But our home on the web is 99pi.org. Radio Tapio. From PRX. you There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
加利福尼亚州奥克兰的注重合作的建筑事务所Arxon的办公室制作。你可以在Facebook、Twitter和Tumblr上关注本节目以及所有幕后制作人员。我们在所有这些地方都非常有趣。但我们在网络上的家是99pi.org。来自PRX的Radio Tapio。本集尚无评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可发表评论。